[Musik]
[Applaus]
die Schweiz hat einen neuen Bundesrat
den Basler ber
janz die Schweiz ist ein faszinierendes
Land ich habe ihn in den vergangenen
Monaten auf dem Weg in die
Landesregierung
begleitetatulation wie wird mit
Bundesrat m
wsen am richtigen Ort im richtigen
Moment ist es wirklich nicht
[Musik]
mehr als Reporter habe ich schon einige
Bundesratswahlen miterlebt oft
langweilige weil der am Ende auch
gewinnt dieses Jahr ist es anders das
Feld der Kandidaten groß die Wahl
unberechenbar was macht es aus dass
jemand Bundesrat
wird wie wichtig ist
Lobbying wie weit geht man für die
Krönung sein
Karriere das finde ich
heraus es ist Anfang
September Daniel J bei seinem
Morgenritual Westschweizer Fernsehen und
anderthalb Stunden Sport in seiner
Zweitwohnung beim zöcher
h heute ist se großer
[Musik]
Tag
oh g
nicht seit Jahren schon hat Daniel Josic
bundesratsambitionen
oh das jetzt nicht gut wer Bundesrat
werden will braucht ein
Wahlkampfteam seines hat der
Rechtsprofessor schon seit Monaten
beisammen
im Zürcher Volkshaus warten nicht nur
Journalisten sondern auch
wahlkampfleiterin Priska
seilergf dann verkündet Daniel Josic was
alle erwarten dass ich für das Amt des
Bundesrates kandidieren möchte die
Medien interessieren sich vor allem für
eines die letzte
Bundesratswahl Josic hat da viele SP
Kolleginnen vor den Kopf
[Musik]
gestoßen
Bundesrat ob SP
frck sind Sie
vermestand wahnsinigengend dass jetzt
überall
entschuldon Diskriminierung gesprochen
haben sie damals Fehler gemacht ja
natürlich habe ich Fehler gemacht ich
würde das heute nicht mehr als
Diskriminierung bezeichnen das war
übertrieben und vielleicht oder nicht
vielleicht auch verletzend für für
s diskriminiert sind und wurden seit
langen
Jahren Beginn der
Herbstsession noch ist Daniel J der
einzige
[Musik]
bundesratskandidat
Jos Taktik ist klar Fehler zugeben die
Kamera will er bei Gesprächen nicht
dabei
[Musik]
haben ja also ich glaub es ist einfach
so dass L
n auch seine cheflobtinn hinter den
Kulen
arbeiten sehr
vielrich
jetztinzü voregend V Fraktion jetzt erst
mal dass es nicht ganz fair wenn man
Daniel Jos nurt verhalte vom let
Dezember wo es vergert hat inklusive
mich aber ich glaub wird nicht ganz gcht
auf der eine Moment reduziert
gzeandat geh he einem lobbyanlass vom
Verband Gastro Swiss im Berner
Kornhauskeller Bundesrat wird man indem
man für alle jeder Zeit ein Ohr hat
zumindest in den paar Monaten des
Wahlkampfs wenn ich jetzt ganz offen bin
ja ich lerne wer Bundesrat werden will
muss Beziehungen pflegen und
vertiefen
ich glaube wichtig ist dass L
wüs das ist sehr wichtig im Parlament
bezieh zwischen zwischen Bundesrat und
Parlament dass man weiß man hat Zugang
man kan man mit dem Reden mit dem
Problem
besprechen Feier zu 175 Jahren
Bundesverfassung
die Berner Regierungsrätin Evi
Allemann J Pult sitztnchbar Matthias
ebbischer und hinten R Nordmann sie alle
werden ihre Kandidatur bald bekannt
geben halten sich da aber noch bedeckt
auch Beat jansz lotet in Gesprächen
schon mal seine Chancen
aus Bundesrat wird man wenn man ein
gutes Timing hat die Kandidatur zum
richtigen Zeitpunkt lanciert garantiert
viel Resonanz in den
[Musik]
Medien Matthias ebischer überrascht die
Konkurrenz mit einem frühen
Start ich trauen mir dieses Amt zu bald
darauf folgen SP Shooting Starion Pult
Schwergewicht roch Nordmann und das
einzige Frau Regierungsrätin
eveman an sein Konferenz tauchen am
meisten Journalisten auf Beat janz ich
habe mich entschieden mich als Bundesrat
zu bewerben im Team Jans sind Basler
größten der nationalen Politik und
Lobbyisten einer
Kommunikationsagentur vielleicht eine
gute Strategie denn als ehemaliger
Umweltaktivist gilt Bert Jans als
bauernschreck ich e immer für die Bauern
und bäerinnen politisiert immer ich habe
aber manchmal andere Schlüsse gezogen
als der
Bauernverband das bauernthema wird in
diesem Wahlkampf entscheidend
sein zi Wochen
später das Wahlkampfteam von Bert Jans
hat mich auf einen Hof im Jura
eingeladen also das S tatsächlich B das
jetzt nicht n für Kamera ja also ich hab
Buch
GT gemacht und ab und zu hil aber jetzt
in letz zit ist das sehr
oft aber das FT jetzt zuf in die
Bundesratswahl ja ja
ich bin alte Freundin von mir ich MS
Französisch Lehren jetzt mit Blick auf
die bundesrotwahl muss machen und se
gesagt okay sie gibt mir Stunde wenn ich
im
Gegenzug Gang wenn
Sie das ist der Z W gemacht
hat alles ist jetzt irgendwie
Bundesratswahl und so sind wir nicht die
Einzigen die Bilder machen eine
Mitarbeiterin der Kommunikationsagentur
macht Fotos vom Bauern
Jans vielleicht werden diese später noch
nützlich sein
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
nicht
unbedingt am Schluss
s
bundesr für
alle geht immer um es zammen und vdam
muss jetzt nicht ein speziell
betonen mir wird klar Bundesrat wird man
indem man sich auf alle möglichen Worst
Case Szenarien gebührend
vorbereitet die Lobbyistin die Bert Jans
begleitet ist eine ehemalige Angestellte
des
Bauernverbandes mit ihr holt sich Jans
Kontakte und viel agrarfachwissen in
sein Team
wie wichtig ist das D
Agentur mir ist vor allem wichtig we ich
Job ich nicht alles selber machen und
darum bra ich im Hintergrund wo mir hen
und ich möchte nicht dass Basler stürzah
quasi da teil und jetzt
Bundesratskandidatur
viel Finanzier das für
ha000
Agentur das zah ich Sack das W Zahl nein
nein nein also am Schluss die die ein
paar Interviews g sie ber was für
Argument sind gut was für sind schlecht
aber am Schluss muss ich die Rede W ich
den Halt muss ich g selber schrieben
oder es muss ich muss am Schluss
V später erfahre ich dass sich Bert Jans
die Agentur rund 2000 fren kosten
lässt für den Wahlkampf in Schale J Pult
gilt in der SP als retorisches
Supertalent er ist mit Abstand der
jüngste
Kandidat Kandidat von der Junge
Z und das so richtig für die
junge
mits jung aber ich la ohne Kat mitatten
und bin
durch normaler Typ das ist Grund warum
ich kandidierere
das Le knapp 40 ist als das
jetztlich die im
Bundesrat Diversität bezüglich
schlecht seit sein buesratskandidatur
wird
Shooting
auf
der K mir unterstützen ich ein
Wintermantel ja se das wä Option das
sicher mal
probieren ja super was kostet denn
der
okay ja den hab glaub 500 STZ V ja das
ist so
aber ich fin aber fair also zu günstige
Kleider h man eine zwiel dass S Soter
korrekter beding hergestellt worden sind
und de weiß ich es nicht ich bin jetzt
nicht leider nicht der aller aller
bewusstest die Käufer aber einfach zu
günstig misstrau und wenn man Privileg h
großes dann find ich okay WN wenn man
ständige Prise zahlt für das was man
braucht GRA
keance ein Mann der Chancen sofort packt
und direkt zum höchsten Ziel
strebt was sicher nicht werden will ein
von den Politiker Parlamentarier
jahrelang im bundesus
sch und hofft dass Reg die
Möglichkeit sich gut verkaufen das ist j
Pulz Beruf in Zürich arbeitet er als
Verwaltungsrat einer
Kommunikationsagentur die
Mitarbeiterinnen der eigenen Agentur
Feinheit will Pult aber für sein
bundesratsrennen nicht
einspannen wahlkampfleiterin ist seine
ehemalige sitzkollegin aus dem Bündner
Kantonsparlament ehemalige Nationalrätin
Sandra Loch bongerell
ein Termine g
funktionier auf
wichtige Information und die wichtigste
aufgab aber jetzt Bundes
mit Bundesrat wird wer Bedenken
zerstreuen kann und wäherstimmen
[Musik]
holt
be Jans nutzt jede Gelegenheit ins
Bundeshaus zu kommen denn seit 2020
politisiert er nicht mehr in
[Musik]
Bern zum Teil Termin abgemacht aber ich
schick SMS
undag einen Batch hat er keinen mehr er
muss wie Besuchereingang
rein die
Sicherheit das ist
eigentlich Ziel ist nun möglichst viele
SP Kolleginnen auf seine Seite zu ziehen
und Einblick in die Taktik der
Mitkonkurrenten zu
erhalten es ist der letzte Sessionstag
der Legislatur eine große Abschlussfeier
steht
an Bert J hat organisiert dass er als
Schlagzeuger in der parlamentsband
Fraktionszwang mitspielen darf wie
früher als Nationalrat eine
hervorragende Gelegenheit für sich
selber die Werbetrommel zu
[Musik]
rühren abends dann rauschende Party im
Bundeshaus Filmen ist nicht
erlaubt doch eine Parlamentarierin
stellt den Auftritt von Bert Jans
online
[Musik]
im Getümmel versucht auch die Konkurrenz
zu
[Musik]
Netzwerken machen ein
mit Fraktion
undon
icha
Situation buschfü sie sind sehr zalten
mit und ich würde schätzen da
alles am Ende darf ich trotzdem noch
kurz in den Saal wo die Politiker sonst
unter sich
sind
das PL
Schug
das so machen sicher immer nicht gut
finde aber mir riesen Spaß gemacht und
ja V vi Jahr schon D und ich ich habe
Gefüh bin
[Musik]
wi für die nun anstehenden hearings hat
sich jn Pult warm
angezogen mit dem neuen Mantel je
nerentscheidigund desto höcher ist
Risiko Fehler zu machen als neuis R also
das ist jetzt v
hauptfgabe blöd sag zitiert wird der
zitige ja das aber also generell ich
glaube also die wichtigste aufgab
generell in so einer Kampagne und ich
finde auch so in der Politik ist es
wirklich sich selber
blieber jn Pult setzt auf Ehrlichkeit
auf dem Weg zum Hearing in Biel trifft
er zufällig Konkurrentin Evi
[Musik]
Allemann
CIA
ich
f die Gruppe beschränkt sich auf Small
Talk solange die Kamera läuft will man
um keinen Preis eine heikle Aussage
riskieren ums angespannter die Situation
als sich plötzlich eine Sitznachbarin
einschaltet
jetzt vi
Probleme
sorry nicht
ver und
das während eV Allemann zuhört wagt sich
an eine Antwort ja behandel das
richtigeand der richtige Auftritt steht
erst noch bevor
Sandy oh
ja es ist eine der vier schweizweiten SP
Roadshows dieses öffentliche hearing
findet vorwiegend vor SP Mitgliedern
statt aber da die Medien breit berichten
werden sind die Auftritte wichtig für
die Grundstimmung in der Öffentlichkeit
uso oder sp60 plus prospektiv
sp60
John sehr gut
gemt Team J P holt den Tagessieg aber
auch der Kampagnenleiter von Bert Jans
ist zufrieden auch weil sein Kandidat
viele Kontakte
knüpftak Fraktion das
ist mit
jedemlich
mit jedem
persönlich das läuft recht gut das läuft
recht automatisiert viele noch Ken D was
Lück geht unterstütz das
die es gilt neue Kontakte zu
knüpfen denn das Bundeshaus wurde gerade
neu besetzt 57 neugewählte
Parlamentarier tummeln sich unter der
Bundeshauskuppel die Neulinge haben
heute ihren ersten Tag darunter 15 SP
Leute seit ihrer Wahl wurden sie von den
bundesratskandidaten intensiv
umschwärmt
telefonier maileschickt Mech oder sehr
abgestmen auf mit B Kaff trinken Spier
am
See
tefonierig sind auf der kollegiale
Schine inne andere sehr sehr
professionell was wirklich auch ganz
klar um die Bundesratswahl gangen ist
nicht versprochen nicht geschenkt kein
geschenkin das ist wirklich sind
persönliche gute
gesprche am selben Tag die erste
Fraktionssitzung der SP in neuer
Besetzung noch einmal suchen die
Kandidaten den Kontakt zu den
neuen in dieser Sitzung wden
dass die SP auf ein Zweier Ticket setzt
und so langsam zeichnet sich auch ab wer
erfolgreich lobbiiert
hat das L
für ja ich glaube
ist einfach das ist also das
ichespürt und ich bin
Sicherheit die Sozialdemokraten werden
am nächsten Tag die zwei offiziellen
Kandidaten wählen
beim Abendessen in einer Berner Beiz
legen die Lager der einzelnen Kandidaten
ihre Taktik
zurecht heute gilt es
ernst nun zeigt sich wer die meisten
Stimmen bekommt und es auf das zweier
Ticket
schafft ist sehr wichtige Tag im Le das
ist klar
aber g berf wahrscheinlich der wichtig
im vielleicht ja so sagen letzte
fr ich bin gespannt zu favorisiert sie
geflich aber ich bin zuersichtlich und
immer Resultat sicher
so wer hat am besten
lobbiiert wer am schlausten taktiert
[Musik]
und wer die meisten
überzeugt während draußen der Winter
einsetzt versuchen alle Kandidierenden
hinter verschlossenen Türen die Fraktion
mit einem kurzen Referat zu
überzeugen
ist alles
gut wie istf bewerbpr v
weiß es nicht D dir
beurteil dann beginnt ein Wahlmarathon
der sich über fast D Stunden hinziehen
[Musik]
wird immer wieder werden Stimmen
ausgezählt offensichtlich setzen sich
die vermeintlichen Favoriten nicht so
schnell durch wie
erwartet die Journalisten werden
zunehmend
ungeduldig
[Musik]
erst nach 18 Wahlgängen hat die SP ein
offizielles bundesratsticket Jon Pult
und Bert
jansz für Daniel Josic ist der
bundesratstraum wohl ein für alle Mal
ausgeträumt die nächsten Wochen wird er
zum Thema schweigen
[Musik]
die einen treten von der Bühne ab für
die anderen geht es jetzt richtig los
nach der eigenen Fraktion müssen sie
jetzt
[Musik]
versuchenhe gigantische Flut von
Medienanfragen ich Hof könen
bestell maximale
[Musik]
abwehau danke
viel uns
regierzimmer
Reg für be J und J P beginnt nun ein
Schaulaufen bei den Medien
sogenann m haben sie irgendel oder
kN propagiert od
D
euris jetzt geht es darum a linker bis
weit ins bürgerliche Lager hinein
wählbar zu
[Gelächter]
werden heute steht ein wichtiges hearing
an beim mächtigen
Bauernverband darum lässt sich Bert Jans
von der landwirtschaftsexpertin seine
Agentur nochmals fachliche Inputs und
ein letztes Briefing
geben die Spezialistin hat für seine
Rede einen Entwurf geschrieben den er
für sich umschreibt Bert jansz will auf
die Bauern zugehen seine radikalen
Positionen ist er bereit in Frage zu
stellen ich will
derure machen und sage Ziel die sind
wichtig ökologische Ziel W ich mir immer
dafür gesetzt hab die sollte wir zammen
erreichen man sollte sie zammen
erreichen man sollte wirklich mit
pragmatische Maßnahmen an Ausnahmen
ermögliche so dass wirk Ben auch könen
das umsetzen und ich hab erstin geschen
mitbcht während Bert Jans mit seinem
Baser lckerli in einem hirsichrat
siegesicher ins hearing zieht ist jn
Pult
nervös am Tag wurde über ein Video
berichtet das Puls Werbeagentur vor
Jahren im Auftrag von Umweltverbänden
gemacht
hat warum sterben unsere Bienen weil wir
mit Steuermilliarden eine giftige
Agrarindustrie fördern weil die
Agrarlobby diese Politik
verteidigt statt für Bauernfamilien und
Natur
einzustehen stoppen wir die Agrarlobby
aber gner der Med gestckt ich weiß nicht
dass Journalist und Journalist wer immer
korrekt ih die Arbeit macht die
bäuerlichen Parlamentarier erwarten dass
ich Pult für das Video entschuldigt Bert
janz kommt mit seiner kompromissbereiten
Haltung derwahl gut
an Herr R sagt er wohl eine
Entschuldigung erwarte immer noch darauf
haben sie die
gegeben es gibt keinen Grund sich zu
entschuldigen ich sage es ihn nochmals
die Unternehmung wo ich im
Verwaltungsrat stehe hat eine
Auftragsarbeit für eine Kundschaft
gemacht es ist doch nicht die
Unternehmung die eine Dienstleistung
erbringt die sich allenfalls in einen
Dialog setzen muss mit einer Person die
wütend ist wegen einer Kampagne die aber
jemand anders zu verantworten
hat der Kommunikationsprofi weiß dieses
hearing könnte ihn die Wahl gekostet
haben
noch Tage bis zur Wahl Gerüchte
allenthalben auch von wilden
Kandidaten mittendrin die Lobbyisten der
beiden
wahlkampfteams nun gilt es die Fühler zu
den anderen Parteien
auszustrecken jeder einzelne
Parlamentarier wird
bearbeitet wichtig ist dass wir wirk die
Antenne und was was jetzt qui stimmig
bis zum 13 Dezember
nochieren was ist wo jetzt dieaktion
vielleichtöst und das ist schon gute
Basis für GPR wo man über Qualität
V das Team Pult versucht aufzuholen und
das Team Jans will sich nicht einholen
lassen die Nacht der langen Messer
Vorabend
Wahltag das BV ist ab :30 Uhr abends zum
Bersten
voll rund 100 Politiker und mindestens
doppelt so viele Journalisten und
Zaungäste tummeln sich im Foyer und in
der
Bar jetzt noch letz Tag und ja ganz
sicher also akult ist die letzte Tag
sicher noch gegen jetzt das aber
WE
bis zum Letten
Moment und das ist
witig die Nacht der langen Messe ist
wohl vor allem ein Mythos die Würfel
sind vermutlich bereits gefallen
alle los ja ich glaube es
wird
obwohl mit glücklich ist vor allem die
bürgerlich so wahnsinnig spannend
wieal
wird wirk langwiige W nein langwillig
ist es ja nicht es ist wichtige Wahl
aber es ist halt einfach nicht Wahl mit
überrasch also das wird J oder
wir
Bundesrat kein Zweifel beim Urgestein
der politanalyse was morgen im
Bundeshaus passieren
wird Wahltag das ist intensive le aber
und H entscheidet die Vereinigte
Bundesversammlung so wie siech verfass
sie tönen nicht zuversichtlich doch ich
wie absolut Zuversicht es geht mir
gut mor F
F was das Medieninteresse angeht liegt
Beat janz jedenfalls klar
vorne die Fraktionen treffen sich zur
letzten Sitzung
[Musik]
die Spannung
steigt und dann geht alles ganz
[Musik]
schnell nach nur drei Wahlgängen ist es
entschieden gewählt ist mit 14
stimmen4
J
[Musik]
der Favorit hat sich durchgesetzt seine
Strategie ist
aufgegangen und ein bisschen Glück war
wohl auch
dabei ich erkläre Annahme der
Wahl